hey youtubers is Charlie I think he
ruined so many questions for this week's
Doctor Who Q&A
again is just part 1 the finale part two
next week hopefully it will get all your
questions answered
in case I'm you haven't seen the episode
yet just blanket spoiler warning for
Missy's true identity
I know there were some questions about
whether or not she might be lying about
who she is
moffett pretty much into that during the
Doctor Who extra episode
what he said is is that he is really
likes Michelle Gomez is version the
master
I think that she's going to be much
scarier for children and is taking that
to be confirmation peachy
is in fact the master or mistress
everyone to think about it
and will continue to be so indefinitely
just a funny
and terrifying Virgin America poppins
the can regenerate
if it is asking whether or not this is
heralding a future female doctor
I don't think that moffett cast her as a
test for a future female doctor
I think he just felt that she was the
perfect person for whom he wanted the
master to be
I don't think there's any other secret
agenda sup let's answer some questions
questioner one jheel ex machina ass what
regeneration do you think this season
depending on which we're generation you
think Derek Jacobi is I would say she's
got at least half a for generations left
probably more than that
what we don't know is is how many
regeneration Jon sim has
heard city got trapped in the pocket
universe with Cal free
technically at the end a time that was
the time like Gallifrey
the pocket universe didn't happen till
after the fiftieth there so many
questions about what happened after the
fiftieth
I'm hoping the second part 2 the finale
answers those they may bring up the
issue compel these remaining
regeneration
personally I think he has a whole new
cycle I don't think that missus gonna
try and steal those are generations I
think she's got plenty
I think the trying to add that in with
already over complicate this invasion
plot
but it is possible they could do that
question ever to pay Rs
how far back in time has Missy been
stealing that people
since she's so preoccupied with our I
would say
that she has all love the car as all the
way back to Victorian Clara
using that as a benchmark just say
everyone since Victorian times
again also raises a whole lotta
questions about
how the master got there does the Avatar
dis is that red phone booth
is tarnished hurt artist just more
things that the finale has to explain
if she has been saving people that would
be that she has the body's
all the previous Doctor Who companions
that's an interesting thought so
hopefully the finale is going to follow
up on that question number three
schroeder injure the cat ass
what was that witnesses saying the one
you abandon
I think that's just a reference to the
end it I'm I think the master knew about
the doctor saving gal friend
in felt like the doctor abandon him
inside the pocket universe
even though the fiftieth change the time
a little bit I think that all the time
Lord's
in time ladies levers on Gallifrey has
knowledge of what happened
in what preceded so they'll know that
time like alfre there's the issue of
grass lawn
what's going on with him everyone this
let their I will say
I'll be a little bit upset if they don't
address what happened between end of
time
in the fiftieth on Gallifrey sometimes
it can get a bit I me why me with
exposition
which number for shadow ask couldn't the
doctor just snapped his fingers
in open the TARDIS yes they're actually
a couple people that can do that
like he said ok you just testing to see
how far car would go
I think the explanation is the car
doesn't know other people can snap their
fingers open the Tartus
she doesn't know the really easy thing
the other way to explain it
is it the keys are something like siege
mode in the locker turn is done in a way
that finger snapping can't fix
best guess though is that Carlos is off
her rocker in wasn't thinking about the
finger snapping
question for five Adrian s if miss he
was able to get out of the pocket
universe work out for is
do you think the doctor will ask her
about it and how to find it definitely I
think collapse we talk about Calgary
we spent all series 8 not talking about
Calgary
what happened in the fiftieth which is
too big to completely ignore
for an entire season so at some point
the Master will have to explain how he
escaped
presumably using time or technology the
questionnaire is
if the master could escape how come all
the other time Lord's dans ce que tu
even though all the time Lord's in time
ladies are special
the doctor and the master are extra
special CD just look at them as being a
little more clever
presumably the master figured something
out that the other time words in time
ladies
could not figure out question number six
do you creeper ass
do you think that Missy will be a
recurring billing like the classic
version to the master
and do you think the Cybermen need a
break again like the classic set to this
episode
so about me as a yes I think she will be
recurring
at least until Michelle Gomez can't play
the character anymore form of it feels
like he has a new idea that's better
just in general I would expect her to
stick around as long as compounding
sticks around
asking the sacrament I know you talking
about the invasion like after that
invasion episode during the second
doctors run
inch up for something like five years
Moffitt has used the Cybermen quite a
bit
so I wouldn't mind if you retire them
for a little while he did come up with
the silent so i'm looking for. than
creating some new monsters
for series 9 question number seventy me
ass
if the master could regenerate and a
woman does that mean the doctor could as
well
yes he totally can't they could
basically look like whatever they wanna
look like sometimes it requires more
effort
classic you explain the mechanics the
regeneration just a little bit better
for all intensive purposes though the
doctor can look like whatever he wants
to look like
or he can make it a random thing
question for eight Joe asked if it was
the regeneration from sin to Missy
and not do you think that moffett would
use it to do another revision like he
did with the word doctor
oh you mean like inserting someone into
their time line
yes I do think that is possible we'll
see regeneration from sin to Missy
even though Johnson does have another
show on BBC America it's totally
possible that he came in for a one-out
seen
I think that at least explain the
regeneration even if they don't show it
I'm not expecting moffett to do war
doctor thing though that was just
something to explain the break-in Doctor
Who
after the doctor who movie in before the
2005 series started
so I don't need to be an equivalent
Warmaster it'll be sent to Missy and
that's it
questioner nine Tom ass if missy is
collecting skeletons
how many do you think she has what he
said the dead
outnumber the living so would have to be
more than like six or seven billion
however many people are alive today
it would be more than that I don't know
how the show that on screen because that
is a hella lotta Cybermen
they have had some pretty good special
effects during series 8 I think mostly
both the stuff happening in London right
around saint paul's cathedral
that is where they were filming most to
the outdoor scenes question number ten
knick-knacks s Carly's do you think that
Missy would travel with the doctor next
no I actually think that we would meet
the next campaign during the Christmas
special
just like we did when we met car for the
first time
even though car became the first
companion in and died in that same
episode
that was a bit of a bummer hopefully
they'll explain why the master are the
mistress
chose Clara in how that ties into
Victorian Clara
thank you so much everyone for so many
questions are always happen to do again
so many questions left at the finale has
to answer hopefully they'll wrap all
those things up
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner temporal pain you in an Amazon
gift card
be sure to message me on my channel or
summer on social like Twitter Facebook
for details
so one more episode ago and then we have
about two solid months
%uh no doctor who in Christmas special
in and we can talk about Sherlock plus a
sherlock coming
so right now click here for my episode
11 video
and click here for my episode 10 video
thank you so much for watching
so atop a pattern of the guys tonight